[Music]
welcome back okay so we're talking about
the SVD and now I want to tell you one
of the most useful interpretations of
the SVD in terms of correlations among
the columns of X and correlations among
the rows of X so this is SVD and the
interpretation in terms of correlations
okay good
so essentially you can think of the U
and the V matrices from this SVD as
eigenvectors of a correlation matrix
given by x times X transpose or X
transpose times X okay and I want to
guess I want to actually show you what I
mean by this correlation matrix over
here for a minute
so if I have a correlation matrix X
transpose times X and again let's say X
is a tall skinny matrix where the
columns means something like they're
each faces then X transpose X
essentially looks like a short fat
matrix this is x transpose x a tall
skinny matrix and I'm going to hopefully
I have enough room to draw this this
would be X 1 transpose this would be X 2
transpose that's the rows of this
transpose matrix dot dot and then the
columns of this would be X 1 column
vector X 2 column vector dot dot dot dot
okay so that's what X transpose X is and
this is essentially a correlation matrix
among the columns of X ok now it's
important to note this is an M by n
matrix and this is an N by M so m and n
m and so this correlation matrix here is
a little n by M matrix this is actually
generally much much smaller than X if M
is a lot smaller than n okay and the way
you can think about this correlation
matrix the first element the first
element of this M by n matrix you get by
taking this row vector times this column
vector so it's just X 1 transpose X 1
okay so that's
this equals there's X 1 transpose X 1
and as I if I stay in this column and I
go down and I make X 2 transpose times X
1 that's the second entry is X 2
transpose times X 1 dot dot all the way
down to X M transpose X 1 so that's the
first column of this correlation matrix
are all of these row vectors x the x1
column ok the second column will be
again x1 transpose but now times this x2
vector times X 2 X 2 transpose times x2
dot dot dot down to xn transpose X 2 and
then the last you and so on and so forth
and then the last column is eventually
x1 transpose times X mx2 transpose times
XM dot dot dot 2 X M transpose X M and
so every entry in this M by M
correlation matrix is essentially an
inner product between two columns of the
matrix X that's all that X transpose X I
transpose XJ is just the inner product
of the ice and the jace vectors okay and
what that means is that every entry of
this matrix is just the inner product of
two columns of the corresponding two
columns of your data matrix X and so for
example if these are people's faces then
the IJ entry of this matrix is the inner
product between person I and person J's
face ok and what's interesting is if
there is a value of this matrix that is
large that means that those two people
had a large inner product their faces
are similar they have the same basic
face structure if you have a small value
of this inner product that means that
there are nearly orthogonal they're very
different faces and so this small M by M
matrix contains all of that inner
product information between every column
of your data matrix X with every other
column now because this matrix is
symmetric and positive semi-definite
because these are inner products
essentially that guarantees that we're
going to have non negative real
eigenvalues and those are going to have
a direct correspondence on these
singular values Sigma ok so this is the
meaning of correlation matrix let's just
label this this is our correlation
matrix okay good and we're going to
compute U and Sigma and V as the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of these
correlation matrices so I find this to
be really really useful and interesting
okay so let's let's actually compute
this let's say I have X which one do I
want to compute first I think I'm going
to compute X transpose X first and what
we're going to do is we're going to
assume that X is equal to this
economy-sized
SVD and we're going to plug it in every
time we see an X ok and I should point
out that if if x equals u Sigma V
transpose then X transpose the way u
transpose a product of matrix is you
flip all of the order so now it's V
Sigma u and u transpose each of those
matrices so I flipped the order V
transpose transpose is just V Sigma
transpose is just Sigma because it's
already diagonal so transposing doesn't
do anything and then u transpose and
these are hats the Sigma and the use are
the economy SVD hats okay so that's X
and that's X transpose and we're going
to just plug them in here okay so X
transpose again is V Sigma hat u hat
transpose times X is going to be u hat
Sigma hat V transpose good
and here's where it gets interesting so
you hat transpose you is the identity
matrix this is a little R M by M
identity matrix and so what we get out
of this whole product is that this
equals V Sigma hat squared V transpose
okay now I hope you recognize this so
what we've done is we've taken X
transpose X we've assumed that there is
something called a singular value
decomposition in terms of these
orthonormal matrices U and V and this
diagonal matrix Sigma we've just assumed
that and when we plug that in some
things cancel out and this is the
expression we get now what is really
interesting this is the expression for
an eigenvalue decomposition of this
matrix so essentially this is the eigen
decomposition of this correlation matrix
or if you want what we can write we can
multiply both sides by V to cancel this
guy out and we get x transpose x times V
equals V Sigma hat squared okay and so
what we have here is that these Sigma
hat Squared's these are the eigenvalues
of this correlation matrix and these V's
are the eigenvectors of this correlation
matrix okay
so that is the real intuitive
interpretation of the singular value
decomposition the the V matrix from the
singular value decomposition these write
singular vectors in V are just eigen
vectors of the column wise correlation
matrix
they're just Augen vectors of the column
wise correlation matrix and Sigma are
the square roots of the eigenvalues of
that same column wise correlation matrix
okay so it's a really really nice
interpretation this means something this
correlation matrix is very interpretive
all in terms of like the inner products
of the the data itself the columns of
the data and the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors give me the the Sigma's and
the V's good
and we can do the same thing with the
transpose version of this so let's say
now I take X X transpose and similarly
I'm going to write that as u hat Sigma
hat V transpose times its transpose
which is V Sigma hat u hat transpose
again this cancels out and becomes the
identity and I have this equals now u
hat Sigma hat squared u hat transpose
okay and again I can write that in terms
of the eigen decomposition of this other
row wise correlation matrix XX transpose
times u hat equals u hat times Sigma ax
squared again so again
in fact these Sigma Squared's are the
exact same eigen values as above and now
these are my my left singular vectors
are my eigen vectors of this row wise
correlation matrix
okay now this row wise correlation
matrix is massive this was a little M by
M matrix this is a n by n huge huge
matrix so you don't actually want to
compute this thing in general ok in fact
generally you don't actually want to
compute u and Sigma and V using these
eigen decomposition of these correlation
matrices it's very inefficient it's not
very accurate there's many many more
efficient and accurate ways of computing
the SVD for example based on the QR
factorization but I'm showing you this
because it is the most intuitive way to
understand what these what these these
matrices actually mean so the columns of
U are eigenvectors of a correlation
matrix and the columns of V are the
eigenvectors of another correlation
matrix and to some extent they are the
most correlated the the first column u1
is the largest eigen vector that is most
correlated with with the data with the
column space of the data the second
column is the next most important
eigenvector and the next and the next
and the next and they're important this
is quantify
by the eigenvalues Sigma squared very
very cool interpretation I really like
to think about SVD in this way it's not
how do you compute the SVD but it's how
I interpret the SVD okay thank you